in hood
outlaws and legends you will battle it
out in visceral
and nail-biting multiplayer heists in a
violent
medieval world
choose an outlaw assemble your team and
then infiltrate
castles and strongholds to steal the
guarded riches within
but be warned your team isn't the only
one with eyes on the prize
[Music]
each daring heist pits two teams of four
against each other
competing for a prized chest of treasure
guarded by
knights crossbowman and the fearsome
sheriff
each castle you visit is located in a
unique environment
with structures to explore and hidden
entrances to discover
your first step is to infiltrate the
enemy stronghold
to capture spawn points and find the key
to the vault
the key is protected by the sheriff a
force of nature
capable of killing a man in a single
blow and protected by a squad of elite
guards
once you have the key you need to locate
the vault
and unlock the door if you manage to get
the location before the rival game
they will have to either ambush you at
the vault or wait for another
opportunity
to steal the treasure chest from you
you must now take the chest to an
extraction point and prepare to winch it
away
defend the position and protect your
teammates winching the chest
both the enemy team and the sheriff will
try to stop you
and claim the goods for themselves
a successful heist starts with
assembling the perfect team
the ranger is a sniper equipped with a
devastating longbow
that can eliminate targets from almost
any range
his explosive arrows can bring even the
unstoppable sheriff
to his knees
the hunter's burst fire crossbow and
deadly assassination abilities
makes her a master of close range
ambushes
her invisibility and smoke grenades are
perfect
for the sneaky approach
the brawler is the best at close
quarters combat
his sledgehammer is capable of downing
some foes in a single blow
and when he activates his wrath he
becomes a melee
the mystic's divination lets him detect
nearby enemies
he also has healing abilities that can
bring the wounded allies back to
fighting form
only a fool would consider him a
pacifist though
his flail is the perfect weapon for
crowd controlling
and breaking down the sturdiest of
armored guards
the riches you managed to steal from the
state may be used to develop your
hideout
giving you access to a wide variety of
services
with your hard-earned rewards change the
look of your weapons
and armor or customize your characters
to unlock new tools
abilities and gear
[Music]
hood outlaws and legends will let you
and your friends perform daring heists
and calculated escapes under the
watchful eye of the state
is there honor among thieves that's up
to you
to decide in
hood we are all outlaws but some of us
will become legends
you